foreign
this is one of the links that Stanford
gave on its site for where it sourced
its where its source material came from
University of Oregon Human Resources
trans glossary 101.
there's just four they're all they're
all interesting assigned sex the
Declaration by a medical provider of an
individual sex and gender is based on
genitalia appearance at Birth after the
assignment the individual is expected to
grow up and exist within a certain set
of gender roles appropriate to their
assigned gender commonly seen as female
assigned at Birth or male signed at
Birth also see sex
I don't know what in what way this is
right actually I think that they've made
as many errors as they possibly could in
a
a sentence a set of sentences this long
oh I think it's right just you know it
assumes a many worlds interpretation of
physics in which there's a world in
which an obstetrician tells you what
gender you are and then hands you either
a truck or a set of cooking implements
depending upon the assignment you know
if that world exists then this is a
perfectly appropriate point to be making
I mean this I don't know when this was
made but it's up in the end of 2022.
a sex isn't assigned at Birth it's
observed to birth or before birth I've
said it a billion places at this point
um so just
that's point one but after the
assignment no it's not an assignment but
after the assignment the individual is
expected to grow up and exist within a
certain set of gender roles appropriate
to their sign generic says who like when
are you living the 1950s what is going
on here like that's not that's not the
world that we were living in until you
yahoos decide to come in and decide that
if you felt like wearing lipstick that
must mean you're a woman like what is
happening wouldn't it be wonderful
though I would love to see a skit in
which the obstetrician declares the
child male and then the parents were
like oh good what what careers does that
open up for them
exactly this is so I just don't
understand how anyone can put a list
like this together and not the entire
time go God this is regressive God we're
going backwards oh this is bad like this
is so no freaking regressive but at some
level look we keep falling into this
right this is sophistry and the real
point of this list is not the content of
the list the real point of this list is
to see if you're afraid of them right if
you're afraid of them yeah then you will
start attempting to do these things if
you are not afraid of them you might
just go on speaking in ways that convey
things to people as if that was your
purpose yeah
okay next run from the University of
Oregon's uh trans resources list
cisgender privilege
um
cisgender of course meaning uh that uh
how you present to the world is the sex
that you are
the set of privilege and and I will say
before I read their cisgender privilege
thing uh I will
call someone trans who is identifying as
trans
I have rejected from way back back when
we had trans students and I we were
thinking about this and wading through
it and all of this that one point a
student who was sort of dabbling one of
the cues you know queer questioning
something
um decided to tell the entire classes
and not a class that we were teaching
together but decided to tell the entire
class that all the rest of us
um needed to start a
introducing ourselves as CIS as
cisgender and I said no
no we don't that is that is not what we
are
sis is a word created by the tiny
minority to make it seem
that uh the world is not as it is so I
object to the i i acknowledge that if
you're going to have trans that there
needs to be a a category to which to
compare it to but that doesn't mean that
the vast fast vast majority of us for
whom genetics and development went in
the normal way and who do not feel a
deep sense of misalignment between the
sex that we are and the sex that we feel
ourselves to be do not need to be
walking around saying I'm a CIS like no
we just daughter okay so cisgender
privilege they say the set of privileges
conferred to people who are perceived to
be cisgender examples having one's
correct pronouns used no harassment in
public restrooms no denial of Access to
Health Care
there's no denial of access to
healthcare thing is up there with if you
don't affirm your child's new Trans
identity they're going to kill
themselves that's it's right up there
with that it's it's this claim oh Trans
people are having their health care
tonight no
trans people
have not had any health care that is
available to all the rest of us ever
denied to them what in some places
people under some ages are being
restricted from having is
permanently misfiguring misfiguring or
hormonally disrupting procedures done
which no one who is not trans would ever
choose to have done right it's it's so
it's not about health care it's about
the thing that somehow you've decided
you should expect to have access to
because you have a condition that is
suddenly fashionable
it's not Healthcare it's exactly if you
identified as fentanyl deficient are you
entitled to have fentanyl distributed to
you exactly and the answer is no you're
not entitled to any such thing the way
we do medicine there are prescription
drugs this is one you can't have it
unless a doctor decides you need it
right and yet the you know the the
needle distribution stuff for heroin
addicts is you know not too far from
this right and yes it's
better to have clean needles than dirty
needles but it's better not to have
access to any needles at all and I you
know I'm I am not making a claim about
what I think should happen in that space
with regard to people addicted to drugs
that they shoot up but it is the same
kind of logic like well obviously the
thing you need to do is just give them
access to all the things that they say
they need
or
we could try to help them not be addicts
right we could Define what is you
hurting yourself and not help you do
that and just decide what kind of
help you might be offered now this is a
harder argument to make in an era where
our medicine has become so prone to
Injured people as a matter of I don't
know
um doing pharma's bidding but um but in
a decent world you would you would rig
this in such a way that doctors were a
bias in the direction of improving your
health rather than
um you know maiming you because you had
a feeling yes
I will say cisgender privilege though
also is not a good term because it's
just ambiguous it sounds
um like your parents treated your sister
better than you
foreign
[Laughter]
it's only spelled differently if you're
spelling
yes sure okay two more I don't know how
I won that point but I feel that I did I
mean the last point that you made was
true I don't know that counts as winning
but in my world yes very much so
um two more
two more from the University of Oregon's
trans resources you can show my screen
if you like Zach lesbian
I don't even know if the person writing
this that knows how to write but lesbian
a person who self-identifies as a
woman's capacity to be emotionally
physically intersexually attracted to
other people who identify as women
wow
no I mean I'm sure just just just just
no
lesbian is someone who is an adult human
female woman
it was sexually attracted to other adult
human females women
not trans women
not people who emotionally feel like
women on the inside no uh-uh bra and
this one is easier to Define than
they're than they're letting on a lot a
lot and finally uh sex
a term used historically and within the
medical field to identify genetic
hormonal physical characteristics
including genitalia which are used to
classify an individual as female male or
intersex
to also social behavior activity engaged
in by an individual with one of our
partners to express attractions and
arousal
a term used historically and within the
medical field archaic
500 million years guys
maybe closer to 2 billion okay that's
how long sex has been involved around a
term used historically sex
the word
has been around
probably about since language has been
around it was one of the first things
that people were using to categorize
other people but
that's all irrelevant this is from the
people who really think that if you
don't have a word for it it doesn't
exist and they'll make that argument too
and some of them will say no of course
we don't think that but then you see
some of the crap they say and like yeah
the fact that the word has or has not
been abused or used or changed meaning
this that or the other it doesn't matter
because sex itself we are part of a
lineage that has been sexually
reproducing with two and only two Sexes
for at least 500 million years
maybe closer to 2 billion with a B
it doesn't matter historically medical
field this letter yeah there doesn't
matter wait I think we are missing a
term does not immediately spring to mind
what it might be but
in most cases a word means something and
then it may stop meaning that or it may
mean something and it may come to mean
something else right
the idea what's going to happen here
right you've got
whatever the nice term for morons is who
have decided that you shouldn't use the
term sex in the way it has been used to
refer to patterns that go back hundreds
of millions of years at least
it's not going to work
yeah we're going to go back to calling
it sex so what do you call the brief
period of time in which the morons have
disproportionate power such that a term
doesn't mean that thing it did mean it
and it will mean it but it doesn't mean
it right now the brief period of time
well hopefully we can just go at a Dark
Age and we don't have to call it the end
of civilization oh yeah
oh yes okay so it's like a linguistic
Dark Age yeah that's exactly it
no that's exactly it all right good
oh it's fabulous no no it's good
the fact that you know a cognitive Dark
Age one in which you stop having science
publicly interacted over
um
is a recognizable phenomenon right
when we say Dark Age we do not mean it
will forever be dark right it might be
that this world brings Humanity to an
end but if Humanity continues we will go
back to doing science you know why
because it works yeah if Humanity
continues we will go back to referring
to sex in an intuitive way why because
it conveys something that we want to
convey with some regularity right
accurately because in this case as in
many cases but not in all cases our
Collective intuition is correct that sex
is real
yeah all right I I think this is ready
linguistic Dark Age is exactly the right
concept and uh and I don't think I don't
think it exists uh in our parlance and
we need it if they're gonna pull this
[ __ ] on us we need to have that term to
explain what they're doing good
[Music]